wyoming has majestic scenery and wide
open spaces
and fewer than 600 000 people
but their representative in congress is
one of the most famous politicians in
the country liz cheney is well known for
her leadership as vice chair of the
january sixth committee exposing the
falsehoods and attempts to subvert
democracy in 2020 and 21. she has
unwaveringly condemned donald trump i
will do
everything i can to ensure
that the former president never again
gets anywhere near the oval office
chaney's stance has earned her many
admirers but unfortunately for her few
of them live in wyoming
trump won 70 of the vote here in 2020.
in afton population about 2000 and
boasting the world's largest arch made
entirely of elk antlers many voters have
soured on cheney we have just felt
utterly betrayed
by her actions against president trump
since you know she voted to impeach him
and has been in his january 6 hearings
and all the things that she's done
we've been greatly greatly disappointed
i just don't think she's very in step
with america
i don't think he's very in step with
wyoming challenging chaney in the
republican primary on august 16th is
harriet hageman a trump-supported
attorney who once backed cheney but has
now changed her tune she's ahead of
cheney by double digits in the polls
cheney hopes wyoming democrats will ride
to her rescue and has distributed
pamphlets urging them to temporarily
switch parties but just over forty three
thousand democrats are registered in
wyoming as opposed to more than two
hundred thousand republicans
liz cheney's political career in wyoming
may be coming to an end but many people
here think she's aiming for a higher
office using her image as a defender of
democracy to run for president in 2024
chaney has done little in-person
campaigning in part because she has
reportedly received a stream of death
threats and is surrounded by heavy
security an ugly fact of u.s politics in
one of america's most beautiful places
rob reynolds al jazeera jackson wyoming